okay so first of all tell me about the
rise button and explain that to me oh
well this organization I founded we
fight for the civil rights of rape
survivors yes I wrote a law called the
sexual assault survivor Bill of Rights
Evan and I testified in Senate Congress
and now here we are 90 miles later how
important is it to use your platform
here tonight to do something like
acknowledge right it's very important I
mean Amanda has been such an inspiration
to me to get more involved and she
showed me that there are things that I
can do and I just have to kind of
believe that that I can do it and I
believe in people and I believe in the
power of platform then if I even have
this a little bit of power that I can
use for good right now in such a crucial
time in history and for women's rights
and civil rights then I want to be a
part of that so yeah how many
nominations you guys have 107 tonight
what are we to get how it feels right
because I know just how much work goes
into that show and all the literal blood
sweat and tears that we all pour into it
we care about it so much we love it so
much and to see that reflected back
tonight is always incredible literally
the blood there is a lot of blood
there's a lot of blood but where do you
go next and where can you go next
because originally I was like others got
one season I mean how long can it go
yeah well I think our plan is to you
know every seasons gonna be different
it's gonna keep evolving it's gonna keep
changing and I have all the faith in the
world and Lisa joy and Jonah Nolan to
keep us on our toes all the time on your
toes and you then they keep us on our
toes
one other thing how did you two meet and
how did you connect well um I gave a
speech at the Women's Forum Sean
Washington
I'm and Evan was there and then I saw
Evan speak at Forbes we connect
and then we testified together in front
of Congress and it completely changed my
life and we've been good friends ever
since
oh good for y'all for using this time
for a good for good I don't want to talk
about close I want to hear about this
[Music]